foreign
yeah no intro on this one I couldn't
think of a clever joke or anything so I
wanted to do something today which is to
compare from a Creator's perspective
the pros and cons of tick tock versus
YouTube now before I get too far into
this let me say up front they are good
at different things so if you are
approaching this as a guide for what
platform should you either be on at all
or what platform should you be putting
more of your energy into your first
answer to that should involve the
question what kind of content do I want
to make because while it is true both
have started to try and eat each other's
lunch a little bit they are
fundamentally built to do different
things YouTube is widescreen format and
at this point is built for a longer form
material you can get shorter stuff
including the YouTube shorts format
which I've talked about before it sucks
part of the reason why it sucks is it is
trying very much to be Tick Tock and
it's much worse at it now on Tick Tock
everything is formatted around short
videos now they have allowed for
increasingly long videos at this point
um some people can get up to 10 minute
videos on there
and that would seem to indicate a desire
to start to eat uh YouTube's launched a
little bit and pull away from them for
longer stuff except you have to do it in
vertical it's built for mobile it's not
ideal so in both cases there's still
built to do certain stuff Tick Tock is
great for shorts YouTube is much better
for a long form so if you have a
preference for what you want to do that
should determine a lot of things and
this is not going to be a technical
breakdown
I am going to be looking at a number of
what I feel are key categories where I
think things can be safely compared so
what we're going to be talking about
here is ease of use compensation the
algorithm as best as it's understood
moderation Discovery customer service
and the community or more specifically
the trolls
and so I'm going to be going through all
of these giving my opinions on which one
is better in each category starting with
ease of use now this one easily goes to
tick tock that's not shocking Tick Tock
was built to be a mobile app most things
that are designed for mobile first and
foremost ease of use is really high on
the priority list and that really shows
with Tick Tock because it is incredibly
easy to use as both a viewer and a
content creator YouTube at this point
it's like it's mobile app or even its
website are very friendly to the viewers
creators as a little bit more involved
in that now part of this is what I kind
of consider to be barrier to entry to
make a good YouTube video
um you're really not going to get away
with just shooting stuff on your phone
unless you like randomly go viral by
some nonsense you happen to get if
you're trying to act actually do
something you're gonna need decent
camera editing software decent mic Tick
Tock you just need your phone and you
might not even need all aspects of your
phone you might not need the mic if
you're using a sound that is just
something that's already on the app
because that's a way you can do that and
not a lot going on around here lately
let's see what's behind this door
no is there a Better Door around here
maybe and yes again with YouTube you can
kind of do that with the shorts format
but again the shorts format is just
worse Tick Tock so taking it on its own
merits and what it is good for YouTube
in terms of like just the raw Logistics
of uploading anything to it it doesn't
have to be difficult it can be very easy
but if you do something simple and easy
it's not going to go anywhere because
it's going to look significantly worse
than most of what's on there or at least
most of what's on there that anybody
wants to see tick tock is a complete
free-for-all anything from videos as
short as five seconds and the quality
doesn't even really matter necessarily
in terms of visual quality or audio
quality as I mentioned so you have a lot
more freedom to just work with whatever
you happen to have and just start making
stuff and to be blunt about it even if
your camera on your phone is kind of
crap
if you have a fun idea or are saying or
doing something interesting people will
put up with a crappy uh look to it for
15 seconds they won't for a 10 minute
plus video so ease of use tick tock next
up compensation what does it look like
trying to monetize these things so
I'm gonna say two things real quick
they both suck but one sucks
way more
YouTube is the one that sucks less
YouTube's compensation is not great
especially if you're just starting out
you won't even qualify to be able to
monetize your videos for quite a while
until last I checked it was a thousand
subscribers plus some other barriers in
terms of number of hours watched and and
so forth but generally if you hit a
thousand subscribers you'll have hit the
other stuff uh assuming you got by those
subscribers sincerely and didn't buy
them uh but assuming you are doing it
the way you should even getting to the
point where you can monetize anything on
YouTube is not easy and monetizing
anything on there you are not gonna make
very much there is a reason pretty much
every professional YouTuber including
some Channels with million subscribers
and more plug their patreon and yes
maybe some of them don't need it as much
but I guarantee you they make more money
doing that than this because this does
not pay well and it also pays really
inconsistently
that having been said
on a per view basis it's not even close
monetization on Tick Tock is a joke it
is literally
pennies it is absurd and on a purview
basis I don't know how it actually
breaks down but it is so preposterously
small let me put it this way
at this point in time at time of talking
I have about I think about 48 000
followers on Tick Tock I did previously
have an account with 114 but you know
that account got nuked that was a whole
other thing and here on YouTube I have a
little bit under 60 000 subscribers and
The Tick Tock is growing faster but
that's something I'll come back to at
another time but just number of videos
the highest number of views on here that
I have is like around 110 000 on Tick
Tock I've had videos go over a million
views and you will make maybe five bucks
a month off that the direct monetization
is a joke now in theory
Tick Tock has a system to get creators
who qualify for monetization to uh hook
them up with Brands who might sponsor
them
good luck vetting those and finding
anything worth doing because most of
those
are garbage who won't pay you they will
set up a system where uh they there's
the discount code or whatever and if
nobody uses it you don't get paid but
they got free publicity out of you the
entire monetization system especially
the creators fund which is the direct
payment to creators based on views on
Tick Tock is beyond laughable so while
YouTube is not good at compensating its
creators it's still miles better than
Tick Tock next up the algorithm now with
this one I am going to dip into the user
experience at least a little bit because
some of the other things that are kind
of tied to this I'm going to cover as
another topic when I get to Discovery
but the algorithm and how it figures out
what to send to the various viewers
are they sending them what they want to
see
and flatly put Tick Tock has a really
good algorithm it's actually so good
that the times that it goes wrong stand
out really badly if you've ever been on
Tick Tock you've probably seen somebody
at some point put out a video and go
folks help me I'm on the wrong side of
tick tock or my video got found by the
wrong side of tick tock basically when
that happens it usually means in some
way that the algorithm kind of goofed
and sent something in front of an
audience that it wasn't meant for but
that happens infrequently enough that
when it does happen it's notable because
normally the algorithm once you've been
on there and have like done a few likes
a few favorites and like some not
interested marking on things it starts
to pick up really quickly what it is you
want to see
YouTube is not completely incompetent at
that
however it's I'm gonna say it's not uh
as confident about it what do I mean by
that well
there's a very good chance that a lot of
what YouTube is gonna try and throw at
you you know outside of your
subscription feed
is either going to be stuff that is not
relevant to you or stuff you've already
watched and even if you said it so only
show me new stuff it's gonna be like
what even is this
YouTube It's recommendation system and
its home feed
um is not the worst and it's it's I
think it's better than it used to be but
it hasn't got a candle on tick tock tick
tock is much much much better at taking
something that
um you have made and getting it in front
of the audience who actually wants to
see it and from there we might as well
jump directly into Discovery what do I
mean by Discovery now Discovery is how
good are the odds that anything you put
on there will be seen spotted picked up
viewed passed around
and again Tick Tock is much better about
this than YouTube YouTube used to have
much better Discovery but it's now
redesigned the algorithm to favor things
that are already popular views and
channels that are already big it's
really hard to start a new channel and
get get it to a point where you can even
monetize it much less be big now it's
not impossible but it usually means
hitting a combination of factors such as
covering a topic or doing a type of
video that is not something already
being covered by a million much bigger
channels than you but is also something
that people are really interested in and
you are doing it at a high enough
quality that people will be happy to
turn to you so most of the channels that
I have seen including some from people I
know that have managed to catch waves
and really ride them usually had
something go viral because they talked
about something that people were
interested in but didn't have a lot of
content on it already and they made a
really good quality piece of content
about it but you can't plan for that
because you can try and figure that out
and figure out what topic will take off
but then you're doing you're making the
mistake of trying to feed the algorithm
before figuring out am I actually doing
what I want to be doing and that's how
you get burnout well one of many ways in
which you get burnout so it discovery on
YouTube is pretty crap and that's sort
of my general thing with anyone trying
to start a YouTube channel
be sure you love what you're doing
because
this platform is not looking for new
stars it has its Superstars it doesn't
need new ones it would rather direct
people to the Stars it already has and
it's almost kind of a fluke if it
happens otherwise discovery on Tick Tock
though
Tick Tock has its Superstars don't get
me wrong but because so much Niche
content is on tick tock
anybody can get big like I said I had a
hundred and fourteen thousand followers
at my height on my original account and
that was in about a year
I've been on YouTube
for 10 years and haven't hit 60.
the discovery on Tick Tock is so much
better again partially tying to how much
better the algorithm is so if you're
looking to build an audience I'm not
saying you can't do it on YouTube
but if you can work with the tick tock
format you're gonna have a lot better
luck building an audience there next up
after that moderation and this is
another one where YouTube easily
outpaces Tick Tock the moderation tools
for creators in terms of being able to
block people from commenting on your
videos
um being able to flag certain terms as
automatically marking a uh a comment as
something that needs to be reviewed and
not automatically put up and it lets you
put anything you want in there so it's
not like you can only select certain
phrases like if someone uses X
pre-selected terms their comment gets
five like no put whatever you want in
there because if there's something that
keeps showing up in your comics and
comments and it's associated with toxic
Behavior put that term or phrase in
there and it'll just flag the stuff for
you and the ability to assign mods the
ability of the mods to help during lives
all of it is my much easier much
smoother and part of that actually is
kind of where the mobile nature of tick
tock bites it in the butt a little bit
because part of the reason YouTube's
better is because you can sit down at
the computer and really set up how you
want your moderation to be handled Tick
Tock doing it all in app it's just not a
smooth experience to do it and it just
does not have as good options and it's a
lot harder to find them and try and make
any use of them it's not designed
for you to be able to easily moderate
and that can be a bit of a problem if
you manage to catch the times that the
algorithm Goofs and sends your stuff
somewhere where you would not want it to
be so moderation tools on Tick Tock are
not particularly good on YouTube they
have been continually getting better and
I know the YouTube comment section is
notorious for just being an actual
absolute toxic hell hole honestly the
tools are there
I think a lot of people just are not
bothering to use them now it's work like
it is time and work to make use of these
tools properly and to actively moderate
your comments section it's something
that I still continue to do some people
either don't have the time don't have
the staff even if they're a multi-person
Channel or don't have the spoons to go
through that and I don't want to say
like they should anyways like no I get
it but I'm saying it the tools are there
they're not there so much with tick tock
not yet anyways next up
customer service
what is the experience like
when you need help when something has
happened that you're like no wait what
no that's not right that needs to be
fixed
now again YouTube has a bit of a
notorious customer service experience
especially when it comes to things like
copyright or uh takedown notices
because it has always been designed to
favor whoever is issuing the copyright
or the takedown notice and it is stacked
against whoever uploaded it in the first
place and it is an easily abused system
and I'm not going to claim that isn't
the case however
it is at least possible to eventually
have a human being
see and review what is going on with you
on YouTube
so I've had I went through a period
couple years ago literally every single
video I uploaded
was marked as not Advertiser friendly
that was happening to me on two channels
simultaneously
and for I do I I know why on one it was
the Vera wild Channel and it was because
of some of the tags I was using
transgender cross-dresser Etc it was
automatically being marked as that's not
Advertiser friendly material which was
BS and I got cleared on pretty much
every time I disputed that and I said
look you're saying it's not Advertiser
friendly review it I believe you'll find
that it is and they would I was cleared
pretty much every single time on both
channels and after about two months they
stopped automatically flagging
everything I put up
but it but at least
they were able to be reviewed by humans
and be resolved now I don't want to over
praise YouTube because a lot of their
policies again are biased in a way that
allows for abuse from people issuing
takedowns or copyright notices but you
can at least get other human beings
involved
something goes wrong wrong on tick tock
good luck ever having a human being's
eyeballs come within a million miles of
what is going on with you I've mentioned
a couple times I had an older Tick Tock
account 114
000 followers I made a joke
a joke
about only fans and about
actually the joke was about not having
or not starting at only fans
and because I made explicit reference to
that site my entire account was
immediately nuked
now because I'm used to dealing with
YouTube I assumed I'll get in touch with
their customer service I'll ask for a
review I will state in my request like
look I'm sorry I didn't know it was that
touchy definitely scrapped that video
I'll never do it again it was a joke I'm
sorry
I don't believe a human being ever saw
that because the response I got back was
we have reviewed we have uh looked over
your quest to review this and are
denying it your account will not be
restored it was a form letter there was
no rationale no reason given
they so far as I can tell had a bot scan
through whatever it was they decided to
scan through and not restore my account
I never got that account back
because I could not get through to a
human being Again YouTube is a pain in
the ass most of these review periods are
30 days that's a long ass time to be
[ __ ] about
on tick tock
when it goes wrong you have almost no
recourse the only creators I know of who
have had their accounts taken down and
then had them restored were really big
creators multiple hundreds of thousands
of followers and all those people
basically kicked up a stink
in order to basically kind of force an
actual human being to get eyes on it but
if you don't already have that going for
you
if Tick Tock decides to Nuke your
account you're not getting it back
customer service on YouTube sucks
customer service at Tick Tock is
virtually non-existent
so this is another case of YouTube's not
good
but it's better
it's tied we've got one left to go
the community the trolls which
is worse and I am going to focus on the
bad here because in either case you can
try your best to build up a good
Community attract the kind of followers
you want have them be respectful block
people who aren't you can do all that
stuff in either case to try and have the
best possible experience and in both
cases doing that work you will have a
good experience most of the time but
when it goes bad
how bad does it go
I went back and forth on this
a fair bit to be honest
because there's a lot of factors that
might change
I would have said a bit ago that oh you
know what YouTube trolls they're not
that bad anymore
but then YouTube shorts became a thing
and the trolls rediscovered me
and they're pretty awful
and they're pretty persistent and part
of what's irritating about them is they
don't have a character limit versus Tick
Tock where any comment you leave you
have a limit to how many how many words
you get and as a result you tend to get
just a lot of repetition of the same
nonsense but YouTube
there's a lot more space for them to try
and do a lot more damage or to try and
obfuscate what it is they're doing
you can get trolls on YouTube who will
mask
hatred through uh a veneer of
intellectual terminology because they
have the space to do it tick tock they
don't and so the the bigotry is actually
much more up front because they don't
have the space to pretend that they
don't just dislike a certain kind of
person
so that would kind of lean towards well
YouTube's a little bit worse in that
respect then isn't it except this is
where one of tick tock's weaknesses and
one of its strengths
combined together to form a nightmare
the weakness in question being the
customer service and the strength being
the algorithm
so
coming back to the algorithm I said
sometimes because it's usually so good
when it goes wrong
it stands out
and when it goes wrong and when you have
had your video pushed in front of people
who don't want to see it and
fundamentally do not like who you are
those people will descend on at the very
least that video not necessarily your
whole Channel but some of them might
so once the algorithm which is normally
very good but once it pushes you in the
wrong place when it has one of its
hiccups or when you have a video that
goes so viral the algorithm decides oh
we shouldn't restrict this just to the
niche audience to their content is
usually for let's push it out to
everybody and that's when it's
definitely going to hit with people who
don't want it and who are going to be
nasty to you
and that is where we run into the
customer service issue
which is that at time of recording Tick
Tock desperately needs to fix its mass
reporting system
and what I mean by that is that once the
algorithm has pushed you out
somewhere where you probably shouldn't
be and gotten the attention of people
who you wish didn't know about you
they can on Mass
start reporting for violation your
videos or if you go live for a live chat
or something start reporting your live
and they can just make stuff up and they
will
they'll label basically any appearance
of a queer person as sexually explicit
just because
that's the big thing for them to do I've
seen a case of where Creator was
reported for being underage a Creator
who was definitely not
and all this stuff but the thing is the
way the system is currently set up if
enough reports come in in Rapid enough
succession
not only will the specific thing being
reported I.E the live or the video get
pulled
but the entire account might go
if there are enough people doing this
and that is another case where the
account is just gone unless you happen
to have enough support to be able to
fight back against that
their Mass reporting system is
incredibly easily abused you remember
how I said that with YouTube the
copyright system is easily abused and
the takedown system it is to be clear
and it's not okay but at least there is
a lot more review especially at this
point options than there is for the
reporting system that goes on over on
Tick Tock you have very few options and
recourse of that
so the fact that trolls
have a much easier time
destroying your entire platform on tick
tock
that's why I've got to save the trolls
on Tick Tock are worse because they can
take away a heck of a lot more from you
than what the ones on YouTube can do at
least right now I hope at some point in
the future Tick Tock will fix its
insanely broken Reporting System but
until such time betroles are way worse
over there not necessarily in terms of
behavior
but in terms of potential damage
and so if you're keeping track YouTube
does Beat It Out
but you know I am on both for a reason
one is actually not inherently better
and actually as a platform
kind of like Tick Tock better
there's a reason I came back to it even
though I was nuked off the platform and
was very bitter about it for a little
while because I kind of like it in spite
of itself
it's fun it's fun to view it's a lot
more fun to make stuff and like I enjoy
making YouTube content
but this is work
this is stuff I have to plan this is
stuff I have to edit this is stuff that
I have to re I've had to do this entire
setup I have a professional lighting
system and a decent microphone and a
good camera I need all of this to make
this happen
Tick Tock I can do on a whim
and
I can relax with it I don't relax
working on YouTube
and
that's why I enjoy both so even though I
did a comparison this isn't to be like
you should be on one and not the other
you should be on whatever platform makes
you happy to engage with or create
content for
but just know
in certain areas one is definitely
better than the other
so that is the Creator's eye view
on some of what I feel are some of the
key differences between Tick Tock and
YouTube I suppose there is one other if
you are a Creator just starting out
while YouTube is harder to break into
it's probably worth noting
it has a proven stability and Longevity
whereas Tick Tock while it's still doing
very well has the potential to be the
next Vine and eventually just disappear
I don't think that's going to happen
it's doing very well and it's got a lot
of momentum still but YouTube isn't
going anywhere anytime soon
Tick Tock while I don't expect it to go
anywhere it does not have the proven
track record as yet so you know one
other thing to take into account
what are your thoughts on this what is
your preferred platform either as a
Creator or as a viewer I focus this on
the Creator's perspective because that
is the perspective I have but um if you
just want to give your thoughts as if
you are be happy to hear those as well
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it patreon
I mentioned it earlier yeah I've got it
too and I need it I can't cover my bills
on this platform alone and Tick Tock
like I said it's a joke so any help you
can give is incredibly helpful yes
that's how it works help is helpful
in any case any amount is of great
assistance but even if you can't like
share and subscribe help me as well
but don't worry too much about that
what I really want you to do is remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
time to give my thanks to my highest
supporting patrons that would include
Robin Moore zubinlude full up to rock
the thing that goes doink in the anime
Oliver B Linda Walters imodelki theotha
Boyd Becky Sparks for nobody likes the
poodle Zach eidolin Tracy scrabot angry
Casper Adam RDL Taylor Shane Ross
Shaylee gourlay Brandon Larose and TT
if you want your name said while these
guys try and distract me
consider looking at the rewards on my
patreon